I don't be distracted by that it's fake
I was wondering how did it get in here
yeah we need that to be in the sky the
night time and why is it so big do you
change it to approximate the actual
lunar patterns like crescent moon yeah
we moon we thought about that but it's a
big and then we thought what the hell we
talking about that would take time it
would take some effort people won't
appreciate it you would care but no one
else would know life care right it does
move it can move from side to side we'd
like to see that don't we have a device
here somewhere that can make it move all
right all right
I don't know if this is gonna work right
now let's see if it can work yes and
look how the lunar reflection follows on
the water ah that's right set a well
designed set by fine and very good
Odyssey look I'm giving you a halo you
are God forces
[Applause]
oh yeah this is the my favorite TV show
of ever be on yeah well for a moment I
just pretended that that was really
happening yeah isn't that crazy you left
your body alright let me ask you
something I've noticed recently that
whenever there is a controversial
celebrity they try and link them to you
to make the story juicier for example
there's this story recently that you've
been taking Charlie Sheen to yoga I've
read that a couple of places are you
taking Charlie Sheen to yoga if one
thing would be guaranteed to ruin yoga
would be the presence of Charlie shake
again would you know the guy I know in
that Charlie Sheen I went around his
house once during when he was going real
crazy there was a message of my answer
phone from Charlie Sheen and it was like
it was amazing because the news was just
essentially about Charlie Sheen this is
when we yeah blood Charlie Sheen that's
what surely there must be other things
but probably nothing else was happening
no only Charlie Sheen is the epicenter
of our planet yes unlike during that
time I've got an answer mrs. Ewing it
would say like a brand genius won this
it's genius tool it's Charlie Sheen I
know this is crazy
so listen to it carefully there
instructions to go to his house I went
there knows all people likes him being
Charlie Sheen which was out of control
crazy and you know he wasn't doing
knocking stuff over he was sat down
around the table with a bunch of guys
who looked real on edge I think it was
their job to look after Charlie Sheen
there was a distinct atmosphere look
like if Charlie Sheen looked away that
one of them would like push a note into
your hand get me out of here
[Laughter]
yeah and so you went you talked to him
just had a chat with Charlie excuse me I
think he's super cool yeah he's funny
he's very funny right right don't worry
they're not airing this one on PBS
anymore I really was over when you made
this booking exactly you ruined it I
apologize I'm like but I'm curious if
because you worked with him once on an
award show yeah this is really cool what
happened was I I hosted the MTV Awards
and I did a joke at the beginning about
Charlie Sheen right I said like I goes
hey I need there to be someone in the
audience that's crazier than me cuz like
last time I did an MTV Award show Kanye
West was there and he glad got a bit
drunk and came up on the stage I mean
it's nice to know there's at least one
person who's more crazy than me in the
room Kanye can't make it tonight so
Charlie Sheen where he can you do
something nuts and tried scene heard
that there was this joke and you go and
he wouldn't he said he wouldn't take his
place in the audience you know something
the people won't be out to a cutaway of
him to make the joke more funny so like
they said one minute before I go back
that goes Charlie Sheen wants to talk to
you he needs Shirin she's about this
joke he's nervous and everything and
already there's a countdown the MTV show
is gonna be on in 30 seconds 29 seconds
so it's a run posh trying to cheer
there's Charlie Charlie you don't even
look sort of like you know if you look
like Charlie she I think he has a [ __ ] on
cigarette on guys right Charlie the joke
is I've just said there needs to be
something crazier than me so Charlie if
I don't and so Charlie if I do anything
crazy this is the joke if I do anything
crazy Charlie Sheen said scotch-taped
under your chairs a bottle of whiskey
and a gram of coke if I do anything now
it's break open the bowl and do a couple
of lines of coke and get up here is that
all right Charlie anyway change it to a
kilo
this is one note to make it more
judgement